[Music]
all eyes on Priscilla and the control
for the Presley family Millions welcome
everyone to Entertainment Tonight You
Know 21 days after Lisa Marie's passing
we're learning more about the Presley
family dynamic between Lisa Priscilla
and Priscilla's son Navarone Garibaldi
[Music]
55 year old son who was with her at Lisa
Marie's funeral streamed live he sent
love to his late half-sister happy
birthday in heaven and broke some
Presley news I think my mom is right in
another book this comes as court filings
claim Priscilla was making nine hundred
thousand dollars a year from Elvis
Presley Enterprises even though she had
no stake in the company why is this
important well rewind to Lisa Marie's
2018 lawsuit regarding her trust Lisa
Marie alleged her own mom was not
performing any executive level work to
justify that salary
[Music]
Bridge
while all eyes are on the battle for the
multi-million dollar Presley estate
Navarone thanked fans for tipping him on
Insta and shared his venmo account
number did somebody send a venmo
Navarone and Lisa Marie were born 19
years apart they were not close in the
Years leading up to her death despite
that they had a lot in common
both singers with bands
and they both struggled with addiction
Lisa Marie with opioids Navarone with
fentanyl he reportedly detoxed at mom
Priscilla's house Lisa Marie reportedly
died four million dollars in debt
yesterday Navarone improvised a song all
about his financial hardship
didn't have to worry so much
[Music]